Why do we get pimples?
Because they don't want me to look handsome.
No.
Pimples are caused due to the activity of the sebaceous gland present inside our skin.
This gland produces an oily substance called sebum.
Sebum comes up to the skin surface through a pore and moisturizes our hair and skin.
Oh, like a moisturizer?
Absolutely.
However, sometimes the pore gets blocked due to dead skin cells.
Due to this blockage, the sebum gets accumulated, creating a bump.
As sebum is a very good source of nutrients for the bacteria in our skin.
They start to grow in that area, leading to an infection.
Our immune system responds to this infection by sending blood and immune cells.
Blood makes the area red whereas the immune cells kill the bacteria...
...resulting in inflammation and formation of a pimple.